alors aujourd'hui on va parler de
minecraft minecraft heures c'est le
nouveau jeu développé par microsoft sur
mobile c'est un jeu en réalité augmentée
donc ce qui veut dire que les éléments
virtuels sont directement superposer au
monde réel via la caméra du téléphone
pour l'instant uniquement disponible aux
états unis et dans quelques autres pays
on n'a pas encore la date en france mais
le monde tout cas on a pu se rendre à
londres pour essayer le jeu et du coup
on vous explique tout ça quand on ouvre
même créateur qui a directement la carte
du jeu qui s'ouvre temps de next un jeu
en réalité augmentée qui reprend aussi
des éléments de géolocalisation c'est
quelque chose qu'on a pu voir notamment
avec pokémon go la carte du jeu va
reprendre directement les rues et les
quartiers du monde réel donc par exemple
les grandes avenues de paris vont être
matérialisées sous un grand chemin de
terre et les déplacements du personnage
dans le jeu vous être calqués sur ceux
du joueur dans la vraie vie
sur cette carte on a des ressources a
récolté on a par exemple des arbres des
animaux quand le joueur appuie sur sur
ces objets ou si ces ressources il va
récolter directement les objets par
exemple pour un arbre ça va être des
feuilles du bois pour une poule ça va
être des plumes et aider eux et aussi
sur la carte il ya quelques secrets on a
notamment des coffres à trésor qui
contiennent des ressources rares et
aussi des rubis l'expérience qui va
permettre aux joueurs de monter en
niveau et les rubis qui vont lui
permettre d'acheter des bonus pour son
avatar et quand on est sur la carte on
va pouvoir déclencher à tout moment le
mode construction donc c'est donc c'est
ce mode qui fait vraiment que minecraft
heures fait est un jeu un petit peu
spécial et qui se distingue de la
concurrence et on va pouvoir du coup
construire ce qu'on veut
le mode construction ça va commencer en
plaçant un plateau un plateau c'est là
une zone car et on va devoir faire
apparaître directement sur une surface
plane donc ça peut être directement le
sol ou une table il faut savoir que les
plateaux vont pouvoir augmenter avec le
temps ils vont pouvoir être plus grand
donc au début on va commencer avec des
plateaux qui font huit blocs parvis blog
puis après ça va ça va être 16 par 16
par exemple et donc du coût des
complices le plateau eh ben on va voir
directement le niveau s'animer sur
certains plateaux il ya par exemple des
animaux qui vont commencer à bouger dès
qu'on lance le mode construction avec ce
plateau et c'est vraiment partir de ce
moment là que la réalité augmentée et
que techniquement le jeu va être être
impressionnant va pouvoir s'incliner au
dessus de la structure comme si elle
était vraiment devant nous pour regarder
d'un peu plus près un élément en
particulier on va pouvoir se pencher
pour apprécier les les perspectives on
va pouvoir tourner autour également pour
changer l'angle et à partir de ce
moment-là il
du coup la construction du jeu qui va
démarrer pour poser un blog parce que du
coup tout le jeu repose sur une logique
de bloc il va falloir appuyé sur un sur
l'écran tout simplement donc on appuie
sur un écran et savage d'un blog qu on
va appuyer de nouveau ils savent en
supprimant un autre donc c'est comme ça
qu'on va pouvoir construire des tours
est également vrai un peu ce qu'on veut
des maisons mais il faut savoir que le
tout manque un petit peu de précision
dans la version qu'on a on a essayé
certaines reprises
il nous est arrivé de poser un bloc
alors vous voulez pas forcément à mettre
là où alors essayer de tracer les
grandes lignes d'un coup et d'avoir
quelque chose qui est pas forcément
rectiligne et droit donc de ce côté-là
ça manque un petit mot de précision du
coup le jeu n'est pas encore ce monde
parallèle qui a été montré dans la vidéo
promotionnelle
on ne va pas pouvoir par exemple tendre
son smartphone dans la rue pour
apprécier les édifices qui ont été
construits par les autres joueurs et les
développeurs nous ont expliqué que pour
l'instant ça va ça n'avait pas été mis
en place pour des raisons évidentes de
modération il faut savoir que dans
une kraft le titre originel de base y
avait déjà eu des soucis avec les gens
qui construisent et des choses vulgaire
ou à caractère sexuel directement dans
le niveau pour le moment on n'a pas ce
côté monde parallèle mais le mode
construction reste quand même quelque
chose de chouette et d'agréable
d'affaires on peut quand même jouer en
multijoueur amène crafter donc ça veut
dire qu'on construction va être comme
qui dirait dans un mode privé il ya
seulement quelques joueurs qui sont
invités à une partie qu'ils vont pouvoir
regarder et modifier la même
construction donc c'est quelque chose
qui est assez qui est assez sympa parce
que du coup on voit directement les
autres joueurs en surimpression des
niveaux on les voit rajouter les petits
blocs au fur et à mesure et donc on peut
construire des choses des choses à
plusieurs après une fois qu'on termine
le mode construction une fois qu'on l'a
quitté on a sauvegardé la structure et
puis après on peut passer et on peut
passer un beau projet avec la mode
construction on a aussi un mode play
donc c'est une sorte de mode dérivés qui
permet d'apprécier en fait la
construction directement depuis y est
depuis l'intérieur donc la différence du
mode construction de bases où on a un
point de vue au dessus de la structure
cette fois on va voir directement un
point de vue à la première personne
c'est à dire que quand on va tendre son
téléphone
on va voir directement en bougeant un
téléphone la structure comme si on était
depuis l'intérieur ça c'est quelque
chose qui est quand même assez sympa et
c'est vraiment dans ces cas là que voilà
la réalité augmentée est chouette
surtout que nos déplacements sont aussi
pris en compte ce qui veut dire qu'on va
pouvoir vraiment avancer dans une
construction voilà pour pour vraiment
pénétré à l'intérieur il a de nouveau on
va pouvoir faire ça soit en solo sans
multi joueurs pour pouvoir rajouter des
trucs
même détruire si on veut il faut juste
que savoir que le mode play est un mode
un peu plus libre ce qui veut dire que
quand on va quitter ce mode là les
modifications sur la structure ne seront
pas sauvegardés après le mode play donc
il prend ce point de vue à la première
personne et à taille humaine on a
surtout les aventures dans minecraft
earth et c'est quelque chose qui est
cassé important dans le jeu donc en fait
ça va prendre la forme de me
d'abandonner ou de grottes que le joueur
va pouvoir trouver directement sur la
carte
dès que le joueur clique dessus ça va
reprendre le même principe que les
plateaux il va d'abord falloir pointé
une surface plane sauf que là ça va il
va falloir une grande surface pour
afficher toute la zone et ensuite on va
pouvoir directement avancé dans ses
structures dans ses mines abandonnées ou
dans ses crottes les aventures sont
directement centré sur l'action donc on
aura directement des monstres dont on
doit se défaire on va devoir du coup
appuyé et les visées en fonction des
armes qu'on a pour pour les éliminer
dans les aventures on peut aussi
récolter des ressources rares que ce
soit des diamants donc c'est de l'or
c'est des choses qui vont permettre
d'améliorer notre équipement à l'avenir
mais faut quand même dire que dans ces
aventures tout va rester sur une surface
plane donc on va pouvoir avancer
directement sur le sol mais on va pas
pouvoir descendre par exemple dans les
profondeurs d'une grotte qu'on va
pouvoir voir même même si on les a en
face de nous il n'est pas possible de
passer à l'étagé en dessous comme le
mode play du mode de construction pour
avoir en surimpression du niveau
directement nos coéquipiers qui vont
pouvoir eux aussi attaquer des ennemis
sur le même niveau et donc c'est quelque
chose qui varient un petit peu du mode
de construction et qui est assez sympa
ça fait un joli équilibre entre la
construction et des choses plus centré
sur l'action mais par contre à côté de
ce côté un petit peu frustrant où on
peut pas descendre à l'étagé inférieur
il ya aussi ce côté un petit peu
étouffant que je veux dire c'est qu'on a
par exemple des ennemis qui vont très
vite nous attaquer et étant donné que
c'était en réalité augmentée il va
falloir directement tourner sur soi même
pour attaquer des ennemis donc ça peut
être quelque chose d
da c'est fatigant et surtout de pas très
précis donc cliquer dans tous les sens
autour de soi est du coup passée s'est
passé est passé ce petit ce petit défaut
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'intéressant et de choix à faire ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que le jeu est
pour l'instant en accès anticipé donc ça
veut dire que le jeu ne sort pas
totalement terminée l'avenir les
développeurs nous ont dit qu'ils vont
rajouter des modes de jeu des ressources
et également des animaux nous ont
également dit qu'ils voulaient bâtir le
jeu avec les suggestions de la
communauté donc en écoutant les joueurs
et en écoutant vraiment quelles sont
leurs idées pour améliorer le jeu pour
résumer et ça c'est directement de la
bouche de développeurs ils nous disent
que minecraft of repose sur trois
piliers donc la construction l'action et
la réflexion
donc ça veut dire qu'à l'avenir il y
aura des nouveaux modes de jeux qui
arriveront donc pour le moment on ne
sait toujours pas quand le jeu sortira
en france mais vous pouvez compter sur
le fichier raw pour vous tenir au
courant des nouveautés de minecraft
heures
[Musique]